what's you're saying is they you think
the job was done internally health by
some of your fellow Secret Service
members if any organizational person
tried to assassinate the president it
would be successful and this led to
you'll go into prison you think a part
of that was because John F Kennedy was
pushing a little bit too much we're
talking about the presidency of the
United States when we deny that respect
to a top official we're finished I think
that if left alone the drunk would make
a great president today I have the
privilege of sitting down with the first
ever african-american Secret Service
agent which John F Kennedy called the
Jackie Robinson of Secret Service agents
back in the day so Abraham Bolden thank
you so much sir for taking the time of
in here with us yeah preciate you so why
don't we go back to your transition of
where you went from what you were doing
and people were watching what a great
job you were doing word they said hey
why don't we bring him in to become a
Secret Service agent with the president
on October the 30th of 1960 under
President Eisenhower I became a Secret
Service agent left Illinois State Police
and during that process I attended the
Treasury School in Washington DC and
President Kennedy at that time had been
elected president and he beat Nixon here
in Cook County by some 8,000 folks they
tell me 7,000 of them were in the
graveyard but that's what political
machine here that you couldn't beat it
so I was stationed here in Chicago as a
new Secret Service agent and on April
28th of a 1961 President Kennedy was
coming to Chicago and also thanked Mayor
Daley and his political associates and
aldermen for getting out to vote for him
and being a new agent they gave me an
assignment which was very low you might
sit and they put me in the washroom now
something else in fact the end and end
of that also and that was a racial issue
because the first scheduled call for me
to be upstairs
in the convention hall near the door
where President Kennedy was supposedly
enter they took that position away from
me and they put Chicago policemen there
they gave me the position downstairs in
front of the washroom and you can
imagine what problem a plainclothes
Secret Service agent who would be
standing in front of a washroom telling
people of another race you can't go in
it was very complicated assignment for
me and there were about 8:30 p.m. the
president drove up I mean its motorcade
came up stopped in front of McCormick
Place I heard all the commotion uh on
the upper level and I was trying to get
a chance to see the president if I could
just see his shoes or whatever you know
it could have been enlightening for me
were you a Kennedy fan yes oh yes I've
gotta kind of defend 100% as was many of
the people of the black race were for
president candid because he presented a
sincerity and a program that we really
believed in and we thought that he would
be the best president to carry out the
program that he had announced for us he
came across as a man who was for justice
for all people when the motorcade pulls
up as I said I was straining trying to
look up the steps and see the president
but I couldn't from the position where I
was and I was very disappointed at that
but as it so happened the first thing
that the president wanted to do when he
came to McCormick Place was use the
washroom step four about the tenth time
here comes president
they lead the whole entourage of every
big-time politician in Chicago you know
everybody want to be next to the
president I was a picture taken with the
president the president walked down the
steps and there I am standing in front
of the washroom and he stopped right in
front of me and he looked me and I me
smile and he said are you a Secret
Service agent you know you want a mirror
d'ailleurs finest a Secret Service agent
mr. president and what about the agents
Richard Jordan said that's Abraham
bowling and the president looked at me
and said mister bolden and he called me
that from then on Wow mister bolden he
says has there ever been a Negro on the
White House detail in Washington DC it's
not my knowledge mr. president and he
licked it and we were shaking hands at
the time he looked at me and his eyes
were smiling oh really
Jim it's its ears it's you just could
see though you know you can see us mouth
president said would you like to be the
first I said yes sir mr. president so
I'll be looking forward to seeing you in
Washington DC I could believe were you
shell-shocked I was I was worse than
shield how the taking it so when new
president women revised room he came
back out we shook hands again the neat
that we look forward to seeing you now
soon said Thank You mr. president
President Kennedy treated me royally
introduced me to the members of his
family he made it possible for me to
ride on the yacht and he fed me when we
took a ride on the yacht on July the 3rd
of 1961 I was sitting there and a seat
on the back of the yacht Marlin Solon
Navy man came out said the president
would like for you to have lunch to
acknowledge me I'm from a dirt pool he
st. Louis Illinois and here the
President of the United States says Mr
boat when the yacht land
we decked Bobby Kennedy came out to me
and we had a long conversation at three
of President ask me what did I intend to
do did I want to remain in the Secret
Service by the candidates who listen to
me first he said you should come into
the FBI we need some more Negro agent
and I told the president that I would
like to someday become a diplomat to
some African country interesting he said
mr. Bonilla he said I promise you if you
will go to a Berlitz school and Berlitz
school the languages in Chicago learn
African dialect I don't care what it is
he says I'll be around six more years or
more he said that yeah he said oh yeah
I'll be around yeah super years or more
not knowing what's gonna happen yeah not
know what's gonna happen now he said
I'll see that you meet your goal
got it so how long was your actual
assignment with the president well I
stayed there about 32 days 32 days well
yeah yeah yeah so then you come back to
Chicago came back to Chicago and became
the field agent again you know what some
of the agents would say when they would
have a riot down in Mississippi and
Arkansas somewhere agents I'm talking
about they would say at best didn't need
to be killed I'm talking about agent
made that statement I heard of agent
make that statement that the president
should be killed
so when inspector Kelly came to Chicago
on a record inspection duties I
explained to him and complain to him
that the president's life is in jeopardy
he's gonna be assassinated but nobody
would listen and in November of 1963 the
FBI call the Secret Service office and
says that we have information that
Cubans are set up in Chicago and there's
gonna be an assassination attempt on the
life for the president to call came in
and late October
over 1963 the agents first mr. Martin
obsessed well we don't have enough
agents to the core around now the
president was supposed to come here
during the investigation of these
so-called Cubans the secret service in
the Chicago district messed up the
investigation in the end we had to abort
and how did they messed it up because
one of the agents called J Lord Stark
we had the Cubans under observation dear
lord stocks drives down the alley as one
of the Cubans were loaned some guns in
the trunk of the car and he's got his
radio wide open and we need pants it's
the car mr. Martin knows it's on a
microphone I'm listening
where are they now the guys took off now
this is the case that the Secret Service
didn't a silver happen they denied it
happened but Mary Farrell doing research
after the president was assassinated
found out that there was a man named
Sierra he came from Michigan to Chicago
and this was in 1963 and he was a
gunrunner so it all matched up not a
reason that it had to be a body was
because the Secret Service filed up I
knew that something strange was about to
happen what they wanted to do he called
me in the office of the Treasury
Department and said we want to you to go
undercover we're gonna change your name
I'm gonna give you a new name we're
gonna pull all your birth certificate of
these things Louis Illinois and it would
be no more around both I had to look at
myself I thought about myself and the
imagination do I look that crazy that
I've been complaining and complaining
complained and I'm gonna let hear the
threats on the President and I'm gonna
let somebody change my name
remove my birth certificate from Sprint
and I can't prove Who I know man they
must have seen me come I rejected
outside
now in the meantime we had an
investigation going on in Chicago
involving as severe as severe seeing and
without any qualification President
Kennedy is about to be assassinated as a
rare was a member the d-r-e
and we had been investigating the D Ari
Shaffir was also a gun run and this was
late October we had an informant right
next to her then he get caught with like
a thousand rounds or something like that
he had in the car that was Valley that's
fairly badly yeah got caught with a
thousand rounds now we could not
absolute the Associate Valley with the
Cubans we don't know if he was just
alone not trying to carry out some plot
himself
so you didn't can you knew you were
never connected to team yellow that it
wasn't affiliation they never couldn't
have got the two of them look out but
here we have an organization and a
severe ho massive area two member of the
organization he says that the
president's about to be assassinated on
November the 22nd I'm standing at 31st
and then down the inside of tab and over
the little black-and-white TV
it said President Kennedy has just been
assassinated he's been shot
so I heard respect to the office mad as
hell because I saw it coming
and nobody took any precautions I guess
they just figured that I was or not know
what I'm saying
they didn't believe it they didn't
believe the vision that I had seen when
I was in DC on 18th they just thought I
was a nut because I was telling them
that when I looked at the White House
there was a cloud on the floor of the
residence where the president was living
and I could not see to the top of the
White House and I took off my glasses I
cleaned them I looked at it Lafayette
Park I could see just as clear
but every time I look at White House
there was the clock and I took that to
mean that something was out that
President Kennedy was going to be a
Saturday in the meantime I get back when
I get back to Chicago now we had the
Cuban organization in Chicago there's a
report of a right-wing organization
headed by Milton he has a conversation
with another one I am from in Miami and
this is in the record book he says that
the president is about to be
assassinated and explains how it's gonna
be done with hi Padre
in a warehouse build how long before the
actual event about two weeks two weeks
before the events before the Dallas
order Chicago with a prediction and
there's gonna be in Dallas he didn't say
where what's gonna I got it this world
the way they're gonna set up I had it
figured that they were they had hit
teams this is the way that professional
assassins work they work in teams they
don't just have you you you and you
follow the president around they'll have
a team in Dallas a team in Chicago and
you don't know the team in Dallas they
may send you to Dallas and tell you you
gonna be part of a team to kill the
president when there might be five other
guys student it you don't even know
that's the way that their work so what
you're saying is cuz you know there's a
lot of conspiracies you a lot of them
and you probably read all of them
because you were participating this year
and this led to you go into prison they
got shown again rise for you accepting
$50,000 and I think you did time for 39
months it was six years but you did 39
months and 28 years so but but before
that part if we focus on the conspiracy
side I have a friend of mine that I
interviewed on value taemin he was a
former cop oh it was a made man and
La Cosa Nostra family it's an Italian
mafia family and he said unequivocally
you know he is 100% certain that the
folks that killed John F Kennedy it was
tied to the Italian mob that they were
involved now how he was they were
involved is a different story but he's
saying that's who was involved they
never want it to be known that the mob
had a hand in that assassination because
it makes him look horrible
government doesn't want anybody know
that what you're saying is based on the
stories I've read about you on what
you're saying here in your testimony is
you're saying that you think the job was
done internally held by some of your
fellow secret service members is that
what you're saying what I'm saying that
we don't lose and it caused other people
to take action while they weren't really
focus on protecting and the president
that's right I think that the assassins
of people who planned assassination
depended on a secret service
so that's communicating in town in the
same conduct that day they maintained
every day they knew that the Secret
Service would be ineffective did they
know that because there's a leak or did
they know because they were watching to
know that these guys are not officiate
they were watch so let's in every town
that that they went they did the same
thing they went out drinking horn and so
they just watched her habits as what
yeah there was it so have you have you
yourself do you have an opinion yourself
having been involved in this closely at
that time do you have an opinion what
happened yes I have an opinion well what
do you think exactly what militare said
is they shot him with a high-powered
rifle and they had Patsy all set up
Julio I saw how deeply believe that and
I hate to say that this thing
assassination of the president went to
the highest position in our government
that there was a coup to take him out of
power because not only was he heard the
southern US but him one to pull out a
Vietnam in the morning to go back to the
stand
as so far it's a monetary system was
concerned all of these things would have
severely crippled the money Powell's
here in the United States so he had to
be eliminated
how long has this been your opinion how
long has this been your thought process
has it because it's been many years
right 50 something raining you so how
long have you processed this has it ever
changed or you've had this position for
how long the monetary position I've
developed I would say within the last 20
years is it because you read the yes yes
I read I read some things but so far as
a racial thing it's concerned and the
hate for the president that the
supplements like military I had that
opinion right off for the Jump Street
today was assassinated that Oswald was
not too long assess I mean he died he
never believed that he was sat right I
mean here they didn't even let him live
for him to be able to be questioned or
anything right so let me let me ask you
this when you go back and you you think
about that if its internal what makes us
think that can't happen again I mean you
have an african-american president
becomes president and it's pretty out
there he speaks there all the time he's
been safe hmm and you got Trump right
now that is not necessarily the most you
know he is one of the most vocal people
whether it's using Twitter or whether
it's doing what he's doing there's a lot
of people that don't like the way he's
doing it maybe here he is the complete
opposite side of Kennedy let's just say
Kennedy who was doing what he was doing
he is pushing his agenda pretty
aggressively so he's also not gonna make
certain people happy you think a part of
that the reason why that happened was
because John F Kennedy was pushing a
little bit too much I think so and I
think in the case of Trump
there's nothing truly wrong with Trump
except that the old politician they
can't trust him because they cannot
predict him he's unpredictable and in
order to be the president of the United
States you've got to be able to
take autos and you must be predictable
he's not predictable to God I know where
you stand
John Kennedy was not predictable it's
during their blues handoff Fred you see
some similarities but yes I see some
similarities but they can kill a man in
more ways than one than a bullet in the
brain they kill me for 60 years with a
conviction
you see they kill the body but not the
song and you can kill a man just by
slander confusing the public about its
motivations convictions convicted people
around me how do you think he's doing
how do you think Trump is doing I mean
you you you've been around you've been
on the inside you've seen a lot of
things take place we're living in a time
right now where the media is obviously
we know the more divided America is the
more money the media makes we just know
that because it's like a boxing match
Don King promotes fights they ate each
other these guys don't like each other
we go by the pay-per-view and watch the
fight and they cash in the checks right
so MSNBC Fox CNN whoever you want to
Washington Post New York Times all these
guys there's a big division amongst
America today that they're creating now
there's some data from Pew Research and
other places that says America is more
United than ever before we actually have
a lot more freedom and similarities
today than we did before but this
campaigns being sold right on what's
going on with America how do you think
he's doing today I think that if left
alone the Trump would make a good great
president but they're keeping them under
so much pressure that he can't get a
ship afloat and that's being done
because he is an independent thinker he
doesn't think along the lines of what's
good for politics I do believe that he
has the entrance of American people at
heart you think what he needs what he
needs his better advisers because some
of the thoughts that he has and the way
he goes about them the end product would
be good
but the way he goes about is not
diplomatic and not within the train of
thought or the the
method modes that a politician would
take the president of the United States
you see he a little bit more specific
with examples of that yes yes all right
you take for instance in North Korea he
contacts the North Korean president and
he sets up for me
he doesn't go through diplomatic
channels he doesn't have the Ambassador
go and hand layout this and the out that
he says we're gonna meet and so they go
me you see what I'm saying in Israel he
said don't think he should have done
that do you think he should have better
advisers because it makes it look like
that he's just shoot from the hip we're
not not goddess who shows that he's
being methodical versus right now he's
shooting from the hip so you don't know
to be methodical around so so you take
the Palestinian Israel peace process he
says we're going to have in Jerusalem
it's gonna be the capital of Israel well
that they've been badness ball around
for how many years since 1947 hmm he
said it's okay so we're gonna make this
stuff he doesn't send an ambassador
there all he does he said this is what
should be done now we're gonna do it but
it's advised it's probably would have
told him to take this step this step in
this stuff and then in 2025 we'd be
doing the same thing President Trump
gets things done another thing that I
don't like about this outer citizens
Street truck we're talking about the
presidency of the United States not just
to me and the presidency of the United
States whoever holds that office
deserves a certain amount of respect
when we deny that respect to our top
officials we're finished we just as
finished as he is why do you say that
because when we lose that type of
respect we have lost the respect for the
top official of our government
and when the head dies the body follows
kata we cannot even know he might we may
disagree with him he is still the
president of United States of America
he is mr. president not liar not stupid
he's not past logical he is mr.
president until he leaves that office
I'm a firm believer in that and we
should respect him as and when he leaves
the presidency if he is guilty of any
crime that's the time to deal with but
right now he's mr. president if they
bring charges against him to impeach him
he is mr. president until he's convicted
by the sin it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens you know I've been here
since 1990 and I've seen anything I've
seen it's from 1990 until today I've
surprised that I lived in Germany and
ten years in Iran and I saw when Iran
had its own ruckus internally and the
revolution happened 78 you probably
remember - 78 revolution and when they
had their fall and it was an episode
yeah yeah so it's gonna be interesting
to see what happens to me and so going
back to the Kennedy's story John F
Kennedy story is so you don't have a
specific name or an individual you just
think your opinion was the man of power
at the top were so worried about the
moves he was gonna make that it was
going to affect their pockets that they
took a move to make sure he was gone -
to get rid of but you don't know
specifically a name or an organization
well no I don't know a specific
organization except the d-r-e who had
this home and severe say the president
was about to be assassinated me in fact
was assassinated a few weeks late how
did he have the information and why
didn't the Warren Commission interview
this guy I tell you why because the
Secret Service in Chicago falsified
reports changed dates on the reports of
the investigation according to its
referring to interference and they
backdated report front dated report he
covered the whole thing that
why if there was no conspiracy the one
Commission didn't I call that severe
they didn't talk to military why these
are people that we had evidence had said
from their own mouth that the president
was going to be assassinated one could
say it's one of two things
it's either being sloppy or
irresponsible or looking the other way
right I mean that's good they couldn't
be that sloppy in you're responsible
that was so then it's a cover-up then
it's looks the other way to allow it to
happen
no no question about so katzenback who
was the associate attorney general who
took over the Teheran generalship went
after the president was assassinated by
the Kennedy went on leave on December 6
he wrote a memo to be a Mars who was one
of President Johnson's age and said that
we have to find Liara Oswald as being
the assassin of President John F Kennedy
so what was the Warren Commission I was
about an investigator goes out now
here's a memo yeah I I have a copy of
that memo that I don't know how they got
a copy of it but I have a copy of it
from mayor fire so this this leads to
one place so specific you don't know you
kind of have an idea what happened
because the organization intentionally
looked the other way and the blame
became Oswald you know here's who's a
person that had some issues and he
decided to do this and because he was in
love with you know such and such person
I ever had so many different things
about him he had parently an infatuation
about an actress as well it's Michelle
Pfeiffer I think it was it's very very
strange stories I hear about him so how
much for somebody that went through what
you went through because of that you
went at the time because of that your
life change I mean because of that you
you could have been somebody being an
agent for 30 years and and you know out
of a sudden your life changes then you
have to go in front figure out a way to
change your career early on right so
what is your level of trust today
in the secret service organization or
the FBI or did you know those two
organizations how do you feel about them
do you think they have the best interest
of America and mind or do you think it's
still a lot of power place taking place
yes I think that FBI and both Secret
Service I just have a feeling that the
Kennedy assassination taught him a lot
they gained a lot from that guy and I
think that the agents are even though
they did a few things in Barcelona you
know they went over and got the drink
and they found agent drunk in front of a
hotel room while another agent lost his
commission booked a lot of things
happened since that time I think that
they're much better organization because
of the mistakes that they made and also
the FBI because they know that their
existence is on the line their very
existence is long unless so they're
better at protecting the president today
than ever before yes so your confidence
in knowing that to do what you were to
do what they did to Kennedy today to
Trump it's gonna take a lot because
they're more prolific more technology
more accountability than ever before I
that's right got it you for me was my
case I don't know if you for me with the
fact that the chief witness against me
admitted that he said after all case
with another ex-convict you for me but
they didn't look at that that anyone
Aloha they did another and he admitted
to perjury and when they sent me to
Springfield after after me being in Fort
Leavenworth and Terre Haute Indiana
federal prison they tried to declare me
insane yeah what do you got me three
o'clock in the morning on July 2 six of
1967 they came and got me from my bunk
at 3 o'clock in the morning Martin io-22
unnies his father psychotic and then
Cuba Lee insane I do I look like I'm in
Cuba we insane you I know very few
people that remember dates as good as I
do and I think you
maybe your your memory with dates to
where you recite them is absolutely
impressive and what's more even more
impressive somebody watching this
doesn't know where you are politically
because back there you have something of
a Barack Obama
you just gave credit to Trump then you
said you didn't trust what the Secret
Service organization did back then
because of what that gentleman called
you do you know multiple times you know
the word and then I come back and I ask
you a question about Secret Service and
FBI do you trust them today you not once
took a shot at them and you gave them
credit that they're doing a good job
today because they learn from John F
Kennedy no there is nothing from you
that is emotionally so angry at
something that you're willing to throw
everybody under the bus very stable on
everything that you're saying it's it's
a very proper processing that you're
doing so you're not over promoting or
selling an event that took place and so
that's what makes it very trusting now
obviously a lot of your friends and
family know what happened wasn't true
but it still doesn't mean that it didn't
hurt you help help your career it hurt
your career
it sure you could have been a servicemen
for the route for a long time and had a
prolific career helping out other
assignments you could have had so how
much progress you think we made as a
country when it comes down to racism how
much progress do I think we have we made
no you don't think no you think it's as
bad as it was in 1960 it's work you
think so you know why is everyone
because people think it's getting better
it's not racism can only be cured in the
heart not by law right now people are
depending on the law to make you treat
me right when I say you I mean blue but
the law cannot do that only the spirit
of the eternal God you see I love
everybody and that is the key we have to
learn the love instead you get it you
got an interesting story you got an
interesting story to say the least I
mean that's a very very interesting
story I'm glad we made the time and you
open your home to us for us to come out
here and visit you and this was great
too for you
your testimony your story we're gonna
leave the link below of the book and
description section for you to find it
and if you're watching this interview
never seen the interview with Clint Hill
if the topic of JFK assassination
interests you click on the link right
over here to watch the JFK assassination
interview with Clint Hill that I did a
year and a half ago
it gets all so deep into the events that
took place with the assassination sir
thank you so much for your time you
forgot man I appreciate you thank you so
much appreciate really thank you loved
everyone